college students have become far more
vocal on their support for socialism
partly because the government has put
them so deeply in debt with student
loans but it turns out that making
everything free is expensive and raises
the question of who's going to pay for
it all Kevin Phillips of campus reform
visited a campus recently to get that
question answered there's part of what
he found I feel like everyone should
have like free education and health care
how are we going to pay for those
I mean who in your mind should pay for
all of the free things all the free
things well some of it should come from
taxes but the government should pay for
it but the government is funded by taxes
yes I don't know where the money would
come from but they can figure it out
okay the people with a good idea and a
good reason to spend their tax money
wouldn't mind actually paying more taxes
Kevin Phillips joins us tonight they
couldn't figure it out that seemed to
sum up a lot of the responses you got
that is exactly what happened these were
all people in Alexandria Acacio cortezes
district I might add and I think it's
it's easy to laugh along and get caught
up in saying how funny it is but it's
ultimately not a laughing matter just
how popular socialism has become
Millennials are the most likely to
support it
we're now the largest voting bloc in
America and millions of them are
graduating college every year with the
work perception of reality I think
that's where this starts as college
campuses I've been on about 50 college
campuses in the past year with the
leadership Institute's campus reform
they all have one thing in common and
that's that socialism is viewed as
highbrow it's viewed as compassionate
and if you dare support capitalism of
free markets you're evil you don't care
about poor people and I think the left
is winning the messaging battle right
now by teaching people that socialism is
tolerant and it's it's not actually in
line with what history has shown that
socialism really is yeah what's just
what the finance economy has brought us
Gavin Phillips thanks for that report
great to see you thanks for having me